esta ceremonia como otras que han tenido
lugar y a las que yo he tenido el honor
de asistir por ejemplo de simone veil se
va a desarrollar de una manera muy
especial por esta calle que está detrás
mío que se llama la avenida su flow va a
avanzar el féretro de josephine baker
pero hay que decir que no están los
restos de ella su familia sus doce hijos
sus once porque uno falleció no han
querido sacarla de mónaco donde ella
descansa con él que fue su último marido
sin embargo en ese féretro va a haber
tierra tierra de san luís su ciudad
natal tierra de parís su ciudad opción
de la que estaba enamorada no cierto y
también tierra de mónaco donde ella
vivió al final de su vida gracias a su
amiga grace kelly la actriz y también
tierra del gato de milán donde ella
vivía en el sur de francia va a haber
todo un recorrido muy lento este féretro
va a ser portado por el militares detrás
va a ver un cojín con todas las
distinciones que ya obtuvo como civil
como militar justamente por su
compromiso durante la segunda guerra y
en la resistencia va a haber mucha
música obviamente la primera canción que
vamos a escuchar es y una canción en que
ella declara el amor a esta ciudad de
luz que justamente tiene esos valores
que ella defendió muy bien va a haber
vídeos sobre ella sobre su familia sobre
su compromiso en la guerra para llegar
al final al lado del panteón donde va a
estar el presidente manuel macrón y
algunos de sus hijos que van a hablar en
esta ceremonia a raúl tan importante hay
que decir que por ejemplo en una de las
paradas el coro del ejército francés va
a interpretar el canto de los partisanos
que es justamente el canto de los
resistentes durante la segunda guerra
mundial a la ocupación nazi así que
mucha música obviamente y muchos vídeos
y mucha emoción también va a ser tarde
citó así que imagino que esto va a
terminar de noche va a haber toda una
imagen muy bonita aseguró de esta
ceremonia con ese panteón además de
fondo